hello everyone my name is rue
my name is dr. Miller and the SCP were
going to be studying today is SCP 29 6 t
7 object class Euclid special
containment procedures SCP 29 6 T 7 and
SCP 2967 - 1 are to be contained in a
five point five meter cubical reinforced
glass tank with water containing 3.5%
salinity sea water kept at roughly 8
degrees at all times
this tank is to be cleaned at least
twice per week at which point SCP 2967
and SCP 2967 - 1 will be relocated
briefly to an observation tank the top
of SCP 2019 Minh tank is to remain
closed at all times with the exception
of cleaning and feeding SCP 29 6 T 7 and
the six SCP 29 67 - 1 are to be each fed
to live clams whelks or small fish daily
when interacting with SCP 29 6 t 7
prawns or small crabs are acceptable for
use as incentive for a response SCP 2967
n SCP 2967 - 1 are allowed a number of
toys to keep occupied in primary
containment such as building blocks
plastic fish though too large to be
edible and a small magnetic slate with a
stylus attached for testing and routine
intelligence checks SCP 29 to be
relocated to the observation tank in the
room adjacent to its containment chamber
on supervised communication with SCP 29
6 t 7 is currently prohibited
description
SCP 2967 is an abnormally large specimen
of octopus vulgaris scp-2932 meters in
mantle length with its arms stretching
up to roughly 1.5 meters long SCP 2967
has demonstrated behaviors common to
multiple species of octopus even those
it could not have conceivably come into
contact with such as mimicry of specific
animal traits and features and use of
tools as camouflage and shelter in
addition SCP 2967 has shown unique
traits such as mimicry of human symbols
which has been stricken from the
document ability to communicate through
written language recognition of colors
symbols and individual features of other
species and that abnormally high
intellect since being recovered
quarryman mississippi SCP 29 6 t 7 has
demonstrated rapidly rising levels of
intelligence which are currently
comparable to dog or chimpanzee which
has been stricken from the document
human levels SCP 29 6 t 7 was able to
easily pass a simple animal IQ test
involving association between certain
symbols and food in a record number of
trials when first obtained and has
scored up to 117 in a human intelligence
quotient test as up
SCP 2967 has demonstrated willingness
and ability to communicate with
foundation staff on multiple occasions
through crude sign language and more
recently written language through the
use of a waterproof magnetic slate with
an attached stylus at time of writing
SCP 29 6 T 7 has learned to write and
comprehend basic English Spanish and
French by observing researchers outside
of its tank this development has allowed
researchers to facilitate contact with
SCP 2967 through the use of a whiteboard
placed roughly a meter from the tank
with SCP 29 6 T 7 responding by use of a
magnetic slate SC b2960a is sociable and
appears to enjoy interacting with staff
displaying such behaviors as making
rough sketches of itself SCP 2967 - 1
and staff members and on one occasion
attempting to play tic-tac-toe with
research staff in conversation it refers
to itself as Levi which is the name it
was given by staff members at the
aquarium after being discovered SCP 2967
- 1 collectively refers to 6 octopus
vulgaris that also exhibit behaviors
similar to SCP 29
CP 2967 - 1 are of average size and have
not demonstrated the same rate or
capacity for learning that scp-2950
as CP 2967 - 1 appeared to treat SCP 29
and will defer to it in nearly all
situations SCP 2967 refers to SCP 29 6 t
7 - 1 as its students children friends
and more recently its army SCP 2967 - 1
are currently unable or unwilling to
communicate with research staff although
SCP 29 6 T 7 has been observed teaching
using its magnetic slate multiple times
when isolated from a CP 2967 SCP 2967 -
one quickly lose cohesiveness as a group
becoming irritable and crowding around
an area where scp-2950 7 was last
located SCP 29 6 T 7 - 1 have also been
observed attempting to breach
containment while in this state most
likely to attempt to reunite with SCP 29
29 67 is reintroduced into containment
normal behavior resumes SCP 2967 claims
this is due to it being a positive
influence
SCP 2967 was recovered after agent
received a report of an octopus that had
caused a blockage in the filtration
system of a nearby tank causing the
crabs that inhabited it to be removed
for cleaning and kept in a separate room
temporarily SCP 29 6 T 7 then proceeded
to escape its tank climb its way into
the room and consume numerous crabs
agent posing as an animal behavioral
specialist isolated SCP 29 6 T 7 and was
able to confirm its abnormally high
intellect as well as its ability to
respond to rudimentary sign language
aquarium staff were not aware of SCP 29
67 s presence prior to the initial
incident leading research staff to
believe SCP 29 6 T 7 may have been
accidentally transported to the aquarium
with a shipment of feed fish shortly
after containment of SCP 2967 agent was
again contacted by aquarium staff
requesting his assistance in dealing
with multiple octopuses that had begun
to frequently become hostile escaped
their tank and arranged pebbles on the
floor of their tank depicting the image
of an octopus this led to the
containment of all six instances on the
CP 2967 - one involved aquarium staff
were administered Class A amnestics
addendum one on SCP 29 6 T 7 was
engaging in a written conversation with
dr. Reynard during a routine
intelligence test during which it
referred to another potential anomaly
that may have some connection to SCP 29
6 T 7 which it refers to as CRO the log
of the interview will follow shortly SCP
2967 has since avoided questioning
regarding CRO as well as questions about
its meaning regarding to be the next u
SCP 29 6 t 7 - 1 have also been more
reluctant to allow SCP 2967 to be taken
to the observation tank for testing
and have displayed wariness of research
staff as of writing SCP 29 6 T 7 has
been reclassified to euclid and now I'm
going to play interview log 2967 - 25 c
playing now interviewer dr. Rhinehart
interviewee scp-2950 7 forward the
following is a portion of a routine
intelligence check performed every two
weeks to acquire more information on a
CP 2967 s rate of intellectual progress
as well as its means of doing so
for brevity this segment has been cut
down to the portion in which SCP 29 may
drede furan stu another possible anomaly
sharing its traits as well as it's
possible disclosure of some sort of
motive please note all responses were
over writing unless otherwise specified
all the purposes of creating this audio
log I will narrate everything begin log
dr. Raina you like dr. Raina draws a
rough sketch of a crab and an octopus
alongside a rough sketch of one of
scp-2950 toys crab and friend and toy
SCP 29
the turning to the magnetic slate 2967
writes like a SCP 29
of a heart symbol before drawing a line
- like dr. Renard draws a check mark
before rewarding a CP 2967 with a prong
dr. Renard is there anything you don't
like
dr. Reynard draws an X over a heart
symbol scp-2950 seven appears to sink
for a moment before drawing what appears
to be a bird with outstretched wings and
an angular beak its skin has changed in
tone to a red hue scp-2950 seven don't
know word dr. Renaud after receiving
authorization to pull up an image search
of bird on a laptop computer and showing
the result to scp-2950 seven he says
bird scp-2950 seven gesturing to the
current results ex-hippie 2967 shifts in
hue to a solid black and gestures to
itself with a tentacle dr. Renard pulls
up a search results or black bird SCP
2967 singles out the image result of
Corvus brock rehén jaws or American crow
scp-2950 seven that word dr. Renaud Crow
scp-2950 seven draws a heart with an
exit cross it don't like crow dr.
Reynard
why SCP 2967 sketches an octopus
a crow what appears to be a human SCP
2967 then draws a short vertical line
ending with a flat line over the head of
a human before drawing a check mark over
the sketch of the octopus and the crow
it then draws one line from each which
intersect above the human sketch dr.
Renaud Levi scp-2950 sevens preferred
name for itself
and crow fight SCP 29 67 draws a
checkmark before clearing the slate site
to be next you once you are gone dr.
Renard exits the room briefly to speak
with dr.
and no scp-2932-a jeté 'td and quickly
clears the slate before telling white
and flattening itself on the floor of
its tank in an apparent attempt to
camouflage itself against the table its
observation tank rests on dr. Renard
re-enters the room takes note of SCP
29th at a turd State dr. Rainer Levi
scp-2950 seven remains unresponsive for
a moment before quickly swimming to its
slate and signaling that it is tired and
wishes to return to its containment
chamber at this point SCP 2967 was
cleared to return to its primary
containment chamber where it was
reported to remain secluded inside its
hollow log shelter for roughly a day
before slowly resuming normal behavioral
patterns during this time SCP 2967 - one
were observed to cluster around the CP
2967 in a defensive position researchers
also noted that SCP 29 6 T 7 was
noticeably more timid than usual in
approaching the surface of its tank
during feeding time and discharged ink
before retreating to its shelter after
dr. Reynard entered the room to retrieve
notes from the previous thing due to
this unexplained change in behavior
stricter containment procedures are
being considered addendum to on research
staff reported a high concentration of
American crows surrounding psycho
whereas CP 29 6 T 7 is contained these
crows displayed no aggressive behavior
towards site staff and repeatedly flew
over the area of the building
whereas CP 29 67 is located stopping
multiple times to peck at a nearby
window after mobile task force lambda 4
bird watchers were called in to
investigate the situation but all that
one of the crows dispersed
the remaining crow which was noted by
research staff to be abnormally large
deposited the decaying remains of one
octopus vulgaris roughly ten meters from
the site before a treating attempts to
follow the group of pros were met with
failure
however mobile task force lambda four
was able to discover an area in a nearby
forest that contained an abnormally
large number of feathers belonging to
the American crow as well as numerous
small makeshift huts and a collection of
various litter fashioned into basic
tools also retrieved where the torn
remains of a copy of the documentation
for SCP 29 6 t 7 kept in the largest Hut
this area is currently being monitored
and a standard avian containment chamber
has been prepared in the event that the
abnormally large crow deemed 2967 be is
captured SCP 29 6 T 7 is currently
unaware of the incident okay that about
does it for today thank you very much
for listening if indeed you still are
and you were all dismissed
good bye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Desmond Hoskins
Dustin Koski Alan Setzer premier Romanov
Tibor ball and dr. mortis thank you all
so much for your support is greatly
appreciated if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos on some other cool stuff as well
as it patreon.com forward slash the
volcan thank you
[Music]
you